it's in one of my notebooks i i remember
wrote down what she said um but the
greater point was just
the limitations she had and i asked her
because she said something or her
takeaway was
uh don't limit what you're capable of
and that was like awesome and i said
expand upon that a little bit
and she goes well i just i didn't think
i'd be capable of this position
and i said why she goes well it's it's a
little bit deeper i'm like
what do you got like this is like this
is the time for let's talk through it i
said if you're comfortable if you're
comfortable with it she goes well
for my past
i said okay like
and i know i'm like
riding a line that this could go really
close
but i also knew it was an opportunity
that if we could talk through something
that
she never has to go through again or
just is able to let go of something then
our day has been worth it like you know
that's what we're here for is stuff like
this
because that's going to make her a
better leader if she can let go of these
you know limitations that she's put on
herself she goes well
when you come
from another career where your life was
threatened and you know you you know
your life was actually threatened
she goes
because
you weren't doing what you should have
done she was like i
i carry that
what was her old job
we didn't ask
i just didn't feel like it was a time um
i should have afterwards just to get a
little more like
i guess information or situational
awareness
but you know
we talked through and i said well hey
i'm glad that you came to that
realization like these are one that
that's the purpose of this training is
for us to feel these things and realize
like hey
these tools work when we use them and
all the other stuff that we have in our
mind it a lot of it's all bs because
it's that's not the reality
and then we did our end of the day
debris like our key takeaway so we do
all the runs we rotate through different
positions
and then at the very end it's like hey
what was
what was your biggest takeaway that
you're gonna
leave this training with to implement
back home and hers was you know same
thing like i'm not gonna let my past
define me she goes today is a fresh
start
and
i always try to
explain that when i'm talking with
clients it's like that's what you did
when you came in and asking a bruiser
hey we're not attaching a bravo we're
tasking a bruiser all the other stuff
doesn't matter
like this is who we are and this is what
we're going to do
and i like to also tie that in
when i'm talking about ramadi you know
when we talk about like hey will you
come back from the point when we talk
about the cost and the burden and all
that stuff
i try to make it very clear when i'm
talking with individuals or large groups
like
we're all going to have those dark times
we're all going to have those things
from our past that
could hold us back if we allow them to
but if that's all we focus on like anger
frustration darkness guilt doubt all
that it gets us nowhere and i know we've
talked about this multiple times but we
have to focus is the lessons that you've
learned
and more importantly what are you going
to do going forward and that's the big
thing that we talk about in the field
training exercises like yes hey you guys
made mistakes but what are we going to
do going forward as a group if we're not
sitting and debriefing and coming up
with new standard operating procedures
we're wasting our time
if we were just to reorganize all right
hey new leadership go new leadership go
new leadership go
there wouldn't there would not be that
progression that we get if it wasn't for
the debris and
the debris are an awesome opportunity
for you to do some self-reflection
and that's what's powerful is that
self-reflection yeah well what's
interesting about that is
this this
training program
in situations like this which
i've seen and you've seen
when it goes
beyond
business application beyond the combat
application obviously beyond the
business application and it starts to
get into people's souls
and
sitting there listening to people
debrief
seeing
grown men
weeping yeah because they realize that
they've made mistakes in their lives
seeing you know women apologizing for
behavior that they know they they
shouldn't have done and it was
negatively impactful to their family
like seeing those
deeper
those deeper changes
that's always uh it's always amazing to
see
that this stuff applies and gets through
yeah
gets through to people's souls
it does
i mean
one of our larger field training
exercise clients one of their upper
executives
you know the company i'm talking about
everyone that we've been interacting
with since 2018 running these ftx's all
of those key leaders
they they don't just know the principles
they actually live their principles they
apply them they believe in them
and guess what every single one of those
individuals
has grown within the ranks like multiple
tiers of now high level executive
leadership positions
and
the individual i'm talking about he's
just been in the game since day one with
us helped us bring the program to them
he sent me a text and i always forward
him to you and leif and
and jamie and dave just so we're all
aware of like the impact that we're
truly delivering i know we know it and i
always give it to my team and i i like
to if i'm in person with the guys be
like hey
just so you guys know this is what
you're a part of
and as we grow this you're going to have
more and more and more of this because
if we do what we teach
and we do it the right way which we are
you all are gonna have teams eventually
running this training and this is what
you need to focus on is the impact that
we deliver everything else
it's important but it's the impact that
we deliver that's what you have to like
strategically that's what i want you
guys thinking about and he sent this
text where one of his
his executives that
works directly
his direct report said
that training fed my soul thank you
i didn't realize it's what i needed
holy crap
it's just
it's incredible to see that impact and
i wrote this down it's one of the things
you're talking about is when you were
running training
you said
literally we could almost do whatever we
wanted
so i wrote down wide boundaries
leadership capital withdrawal return on
investment
so
it reminded me
of when we went back and you were
running training and we literally could
do whatever we wanted
and the reason why is because the
training we produced delivered results
it we had guys come back from deployment
saying
the hard training you guys put us
through
kept us alive
it kept us alive and i remember when i
was being an absolute jackass at
training
i won't be very clear i i've said this
multiple times i always want
i know i'm in a unique position working
at echelon front
i wasn't this phenomenal leader in the
seal teams i wasn't like seth
or leif or you or dave i was in some
unique positions
and there was times where i was a good
leader but i also know that i was a
jackass and that i was
you know that i was that that guy that
my leadership had to deal with so
there's no happening there's no one on
the team there's no one at the echelon
front team that doesn't have that caveat
bro no one just fyi yeah but
i mean we want to start pulling apart
you know yeah yeah you want to go deep
how deep you want to go i know but
there's no one that's why we're here yes
and i know but i also know
that because i have that background
perspective i do at times appeal to a
larger base
than some of the other instructors
because
i can relate to all the different levels
and and i get that so i want to be when
i'm like talking through this stuff i
want to be like i don't think i was this
phenomenal like perfect leader in the
military i was
a good team guy i think i think i was a
good team guy i believed in the mission
and i remember when you pulled me aside
because i was struggling with some
personal stuff that was starting to
affect me professionally
that's when you told me like hey
your job
is to be the best damn instructor that
you can be so that we don't have to put
our uniform on to go to another funeral
and i know i've shared that story before
multiple times
is when i realized that
it just changed my
perspective
and when we started delivering that
impact
that's why we were able to do whatever
with with training
and
because the amount of leadership capital
that you built within our community by
delivering the absolute best training
it allows us to make large withdrawals
but if you make a large withdrawal that
has a high return
you're actually at a higher level when
you come back it's like basic investing
i'm gonna pull a hundred dollars out but
it's gonna make me 150
cool keep doing that
every time you've ever made a withdrawal
in your
career especially in tasking a bruiser
and i trade it
the return on that investment was
ridiculous
and that's what we try to tell companies
like hey
if you're going to make a withdrawal
there better be a large investment
there better be a large investment and
the more
relationships you have within your team
the more trust the more trust you have
the more influence and you can actually
go out and do those things and that's
what people see real time in the
training